(yelling)
- I'm in a hood softball league.
We done had people from
numerous backgrounds that did
negative stuff.
Guys that sit up there
and rob, people that
sit up there and sell dope.
- Well, they went to prison;
they went to jail, but when
we started this league,
they came together.
The purpose of this league
was to bring all The Crips
together and be a family. Well,
if it wasn't this softball
league I would've never met Tree.
(upbeat music)
(baseball struck)
(upbeat tuba music)
Fighting within The Crips
is common and can often
be very deadly. In 2016,
a group of neighborhoods
in Los Angeles got together
to form a softball league
as a way to heal the community.
- I've been though a whole
decent a lot; I've been shot
six times; I've been
around the dope dealing;
I've done been around the
territory battles; and when I hit
the streets, I learned the
street way of doing things, and
I had to just sit up there
and, you know what I'm saying,
ride the roller coaster.
(upbeat music)
- I met Terrell out here
playing softball in this league.
And what I'm trying to do is
put something positive back
into him.
- It's still curving?
- [Terrell Williams] A lil bit!
- I grew up with the negative,
and then I turned positive.
You know what I'm saying,
trying to be a better example to him.
- I look at Tree as a brother.
(baseball hits)
(woos)
We play Mondays, Wednesdays,
Fridays, Saturday together,
and sometimes Sundays.
What's up Tree, you run outta gas?
(laughing)
- Man, we even do a batting
practice at 3 o'clock
in the morning; he can
call me at any time,
you know what I'm saying,
and I'm there for him.
- He always say that, "I got
the talent, and you gotta
"good future in front of
you, but you gunna have a lot
"of people come at you, where
they trying to bring you down
"and talk about you-you
just gotta leave that out
"the picture, and stay focused."
- When I see something, that
you know what I'm saying,
that I can help him with,
I don't hesitate at all.
Because his happiness is my happiness.
- I hope you ain't thinking
y'all gonna blow us out.
- You'll understand by the time
we be raising that trophy up
- We together right now.
But next week, I ain't gonna
know who you are.
- Oh, OK.
(laughing)
(upbeat music)
- Despite being on rival
teams, Tree and Terrell have
formed a family-like bond;
a league that started with
four teams has quickly doubled to eight,
and it's helping people come
together in ways that was once
unheard of.
- Everybody needs a friend
at the end of the day.
And that's what I try to be
to Terrell-somebody that,
you know what I'm
saying, he can depend on.
- When we come together,
it's just a beautiful thing.
There's no drama; you don't
see no police coming out,
messing with us.
- This is what our self-therapy
is: we come out here,
and we just trying show love.
(cheering)